Hi, I'm Jennifer Rizzi and I'm here at the brand-new Nutella Bar in Eataly.
Now, let me tell you this is pretty much a chocolate lover's paradise.
You can get all kinds of Nutella-inspired treats here, from muffins to bread to crepes.
In fact, I'm just about to try one of these delicious-looking Nutella crepes right now.
Hmm, that smells pretty good.
I'll let you know how it goes.
Today, we will open our first Nutella Bar in New York.
We opened our first Nutella Bar in December in Chicago...
...and we decided to open also for the summer our first store here.
It's really important to create a new concept every time.
But most of all, we want to serve to our customer what we love, and we love Nutella.
The taste is so good but is not too sweet,...
...and it's easy to put over everything like cookies, bread, crepes, muffin.
You can spread it over everything.
We are a little bit scared to have a line, a huge line today, outside,...
...but fortunately today is a beautiful day and it's not raining.
This is, I think, the best way to serve and to produce the food in front of the people.
We don't have a secret.
The only secret is Nutella, what they put inside.
All right, time for the moment of truth.
Here's the taste test.
Now, that is a chocolate lover's dream.
Reporting for the New York Daily News, I'm Jennifer Rizzi.